die erkältungssaison geht jetzt erst
richtig los das bedeutet aber hilft
vitamin c wirklich gegen erkältungen
nichts immer ob ihr euch mit vitamin c
etwas gutes tut oder ob es auch gleich
lassen könnt das klären wir jetzt
[Musik]
willkommen bei meyle freunde der sonne
ich bin es wieder mal eure chemikerin
das vertrauen und das ist leider
sporting ein viel größerer chemiker des
vertrags zweifache nobelpreisträger 1954
für chemie und 1963 den
friedensnobelpreis bayer sich gegen
atomwaffentests einsetzt 1970 brachte er
ein buch heraus mit dem namen weil sie
in der common code er war davon
überzeugt dass vitamin c gegen
erkältungen hilft ungefähr so überzeugt
wie viele von uns ist heute sind denn
mit ihm gingen die ganze vitamin c hype
welle los die bis heute nicht abgeflacht
ist also normalerweise braucht man pro
tag 90 bis 110 milligramm vitamin c denn
vitamin c ist wichtig unter anderem für
verschiedene stoffwechselprozesse es ist
auch ein antioxidans hierzulande hat man
eigentlich keinen vitamin c mangel
trotzdem kann man im drogeriemarkt
vitamintabletten kaufen mit dosen von
200 milligramm aufwärts teilweise sehr
viel aufwärts denn viel vitamin c hilft
ja gegen erkältungen das sagt er ja auch
schon lange sporting aber auch chemie
kann des vertrauens darf man nicht immer
vertrauen denn selbst chemiker können
auch mal irren beziehungsweise die
wissenschaft kann auch ihren weil gerade
medizinische zusammenhänge so
kompliziert sind dass man viele studien
und viele ergebnisse braucht bis sich
ein klares bild zusammenfügt und weil
medizinische studien so verwirrend sind
gibt es die sogenannte corporate
kollaboration ein internationales
unabhängiges netzwerk von
wissenschaftlern und ärzten die schauen
sich dann zu einem bestimmten thema
möglichst viele medizinische studien an
bewerten sie wägen sie gegeneinander ab
und fassen sie zusammen
sie veröffentlichen so genannte reviews
ein review ist quasi eine studie über
studien es gibt ein
und seine rolle bei erkältungen und das
ist sehr interessant und verlässliche
daten zu bekommen hat man sich bei
diesem level nur sogenannte
kontrollierte studien angeschaut was
heißt das stellt euch vor ihr seid
vorschauen ihr wollt jetzt testen ob
vitamin c gegen erkältungen hilft dann
reicht es nicht dass ihr ein fachleuten
vitamintabletten geht und schaut ob es
ihnen besser geht denn egal was in einer
tablette wirklich drin ist
allein die erwartung dass es mir durch
diese tablette besser geht kann dazu
führen dass es mir wirklich besser geht
da zewo effekt deswegen braucht ihr eine
kontrollgruppe also eine zweite
testgruppe denen ihr nur placebos
verabreicht also schein pillen ohne
vitamin c und nur wenn es einer
testgruppe mit vitamin c signifikant
besser geht als der kontrollgruppe mit
dem placebo es nur dann das vitamin c
wirksam
also merkt euch wenn ihr aussagekräftige
studien haben wollt dann braucht ihr
kontrollierte studien so es gibt einige
kontrollierte studien die untersucht
haben ob vitamin c erkältungen vorbild
also ob eine tägliche hohe dosis vitamin
c das risiko verringert sich zu erkennen
im review wurden 29 studien
zusammengefasst mit insgesamt über
11.000 teilnehmern das sind viele
das ist statistisch erstmal super nur
ihr könnt jetzt nicht einfach die
ergebnisse dieser 29 studien
zusammenzählen durch 29 teilen und das
war's denn eine studie mit wenigen
teilnehmern und starker statistischer
streuung hat weniger aussagekraft als
eine andere studie mit vielen
teilnehmern und wenig statistischer
streuung oder vielleicht hat die eine
studie eine bestimmte gruppe von
menschen untersucht die nicht so gut
vergleichbar sind mit teilnehmern
anderer studien deswegen müsst ihr eine
sogenannte meta analyse machen
bei der ihr die ergebnisse verschiedener
studien sinnvoll gegeneinander abwägt
und gewichtet ein gängiges mittel bei
solchen meta analysen ist der so
genannte first plot manchmal auch
programm genannt
sagen wir wir machen eine metaanalyse
von fünf verschiedenen studien
jede studie hat untersucht ob das
erkältungsrisiko sinkt wenn man wie tbc
zu sich nimmt
1 ist unser referenzwerte sagen wir in
studie 1 hat man beobachtet dass das
risiko um die
hälfte sinkt dann ist das ergebnis 0 5
gegen studiert zwei war das risiko mehr
oder weniger gleich studie drei hat ein
verdoppeltes risiko gemessen also zwei
und so weiter jetzt ist jede studie hier
nur durch einen mittelwert dargestellt
würden wir dieselbe studie mit anderen
versuchsteilnehmern wiederholen würde
der mittelwert etwas weiter links oder
rechts liegen deswegen berichtet man für
jede studie ein sogenanntes
konfidenzintervall statt eines punktwert
habe ich einen balken
je kleiner das konfidenzintervall desto
sicherer kann ich mir über den
mittelwert sein also je kürzer dieser
balken desto genauer ist mein punkt wir
sollten also nicht schauen wie die
punkte um die referenz linie verteilt
sind sondern wie die balten verteilt
sind um das noch deutlicher zu machen
macht man die punkte mit weniger
aussagekraft kleiner und die mit großer
aussagekraft größer und entsprechend
muss man diese verschiedenen ergebnisse
auch verschieden stark gewichten bekommt
am ende auf ein gesamtergebnis genau
dasselbe hat man jetzt mit diesen 29
studien gemacht hier ist der plot lasst
euch nicht irritieren von diesen teilen
ein teil des quasi in der optische
abkürzung wenn der viel arbeiten zu
einer seite hin keinen platz hat dann
müsst ihr euch die andere hälfte
symmetrisch hin zu denken hast man alle
studien zusammen reduziert vitamin c das
risiko sich zu erkälten um gerade mal 0
bis 6 prozent also bei diesem ergebnis
sind jetzt aber fünf studien nicht
einbezogen die sind hier extra
aufgeführt denn bei diesen studien hat
man keine 08 15 bevölkerung untersucht
sondern sehr spezielle gruppen die
schlecht vergleichbar sind nämlich
marathonläufer skiläufer und kanadische
soldaten in einem super aktiven einsatz
bei diesen gruppen mit akuter hoher
körperlicher belastung führte vitamin c
zu einer deutlichen verringerung des
erkältungs risikos unterm strich eine
verringerung um 36 bis 65 prozent gut
die skifahrer und die soldaten das war
jeweils nur eine studie aber bei den
marathon läufern waren es immerhin drei
studien also liebe marathonläufer wenn
man jetzt keinen marathon läuft erkältet
man sich zwar nicht seltener aber wenn
es einmal erwischt
dann dauert die erkältung nicht so lang
das spart man zumindest bei einer
weiteren meta analyse heraus bei
erwachsenen verkürzte sich die
erkältungs phase um acht prozent bei
kindern sogar um 14 prozent
fassen wir zusammen viel vitamin c senkt
nicht das risiko sich zu erkälten
es sei denn man ist marathonläufer und
eventuell auch skifahrer oder soldatin
der so praktisch aber die erkältungs
dauer kann sich verkürzen
außerdem fand man bei keiner der studie
nebenwirkungen von hohen vitamin c dosen
doch wenn ihr vitamin c junkies kennt
dann schickt ihnen gerne dieses video so
ich muss jetzt noch wissen was mit euch
ist nämlich nehmt ihr regelmäßig
vitamine oder andere
nahrungsergänzungsmittel und wenn ja
welche verratet es mir unter dem hashtag
extra unter demselben hashtag könnt ihr
auch generell fragen stellen zu und
nahrungsergänzungsmitteln denn dazu
werde ich dann in zukunft ein weiteres
video machen wir sehen uns nächsten
donnerstag bis dahin sicher